[Musique]
chaque mois sur rai tv 78 nous vous
proposons de prendre le temps pour
évoquer un sujet une thématique et
aujourd'hui il est question des déserts
médicaux plus de onze mille communes
sont concernées en france et pas
uniquement dans les zones rurales les
zones urbaines aux portes de paris comme
saint quentin en yvelines
elles sont aussi concernés et
gynécologues pédiatres ophtalmologue
sont parmi les spécialistes chez qui il
est le plus difficile d'obtenir un
rendez-vous et le constat devient de
plus en plus similaires chez les
généralistes
elle nous avons voulu dresser un état
des lieux mais aussi abordé les
solutions mises en place
la maison médicale prime d'installation
ce qui marche et ce qui ne fonctionne
pas encore être déserts médicaux état
des lieux et solution c'est le dossier
de la rédaction
[Musique]
les yvelines troisième département d'île
de france concernant le nombre de
médecins le territoire yvelinois compte
2068 médecin 2008 généralistes selon les
chiffres de l'agencé régionale de santé
l'âge moyen est de 53 59 ans et pour les
spécialistes la moyenne atteint 64 5 ans
avec un impact sur l'évolution entre
2011 et 2017 l'écart entre les
praticiens entrants et sortants
s'accroît en six ans les yvelines ont
perdu 109 généraliste et 154
spécialistes une situation expliquée par
la non compensation des départs à la
retraite
les médecins ne peuvent plus répondre à
la demande de la population sachant
qu'en même temps que le déficit
s'accroît c'est en dans les yvelines de
la population augmenter et donc c'est
pour ça qu'on se retrouve avec des
grosses difficultés de prise en charge
des patients
la rs classe des communes en deux
catégories en fonction du nombre de
médecins par habitant
les ips zone d'intervention prioritaire
et les axes zone d'action
complémentaires dans les yvelines et
communes rurales sont principalement
classé en zip actuellement 178 médecins
exercent sur saint quentin en yvelines
132 médecins généralistes et 46 médecins
spécialistes sur les douze communes 8
sont concernés par le classement de la
rs notamment les clayes-sous-bois trappe
et la verrière classé en zone
d'intervention prioritaire
les villes qui se sont le plus
industrialisé où on vu d'abord dans les
années 60-70 s'installer les médecins et
ceux qui sont installés dans les années
1970 sont en train de partir et après
les nouvelles communes tailles et types
driancourt elancourt les médecins sont
arrivés plus tard se sont installés plus
tard et donc partiront plus tard donc le
déficit qui apparaît actuellement il est
surtout sur ces communes où
l'installation s'est faite dans les
années 70 classés en zip ou en zac les
communes peuvent bénéficier des aides
pour attirer des médecins et les
praticiens s'installant dans ces zones
disposent d'accompagnement c'est d'abord
le contrat d' aides à l'installation des
médecins ce qu'on appelle le kaïm qu'il
a est accessible dans les îles
et pour les médecins qui s'installent en
première installation qui permet un
financement à hauteur de 50 mille euros
c'est le contrat de praticiens
territoriale de médecine générale
le pt mg qui hélas est accessible autant
dans les zac que dans les iep ans et qui
permet de garantir un revenu brut
mensuel de 6900 euros
d'autres mesures peuvent être aussi
envisagées le gouvernement a engagé une
réforme sur le sujet ma santé 2022
[Musique]
des permanences d'installation mensuel
pour préparer les médecins à la pratique
libérale un moyen de remédier au
problème des zones sous denses
cette praticienne remplace actuellement
deux médecins sur versailles et le ch
est née elle a décidé de s'installer
avec une consoeur cette réunion nous
aide à savoir quelles procédures
engagées dans quel ordre surtout parce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'intervenants a
rencontré avant l'installation
définitive et c'est parfois un peu flou
il faut effectivement aider à
l'installation il faut donner envie aux
internes en médecine de faire de la
médecine de ville qui n'a rien à voir
avec la médecine hospitalière alors il
ya maintenant beaucoup plus de stages en
cabinet libéral qu'auparavant mais moi
c'est vraiment mon stage de médecine
libérale qui m'a donné envie à près de
m'installer promouvoir l'activité
libérale en accompagnant les médecins
dans leur projet l'objectif de ces
réunions individuelles des conseils de
l' agence régionale de santé de l'union
régionale des professionnels de santé de
l'ordre des médecins et de l'assurance
maladie
il ya quand même des projets à ces
mouvements qui sont pas très loin de
votre notre lieu d'installation prévu
voilà je vous dis juste si jamais cela
que vous correspondre il ya des aides
qui peuvent permettre de démarrer si
nous avons un médecin qui a vraiment un
projet très stabiliser les conseils vont
pas être les mêmes car médecin qui va
nous parler d'une commune effectivement
le rôle de la herray cela va être de
mettre de faire le lien avec les
communes qui sont en demande de médecins
donc il me contacter par téléphone
portable par mail et on les accompagne
jusqu'au moment de leur installation
voir un petit peu après quand ils ont
des questions très concrètes ça peut
être sur les démarches administratives
mais ça peut être aussi sur des
questions personnelles par rapport à
leur charge personnelle au dossier
d'accessibilité pour les locaux toute
question relative à leur installation
ces permanences et existe depuis 2012 en
ile de france dans les yvelines 67
médecins ont été reçus 45 sont installés
parmi eux huit exerce sur saint quentin
en yvelines dont trois généralistes la
qualité de vie un critère de choix pour
le lieu d'exercice des professionnels de
santé
nous avons la population médicale qui
s'est fait mise
et il faut donc pour la femme médecin
elle a besoin d'avoir une crèche elle a
besoin d'avoir des écoles elle a besoin
si pour s'occuper de sa vie familiale
que tout ça soit à disposition autour
d'elle et autour de son exercice
l'agencé régionale de santé vise aussi
des étudiants en médecine avec le
contrat d'engagement de service public
le financement des études en échange
d'un engagement d'installation dans une
zone sous denses
[Musique]
cette généralistes un pour quatre mille
cinq cent cinquante habitants trappe et
en zone d'intervention prioritaire
ce médecin généraliste est arrivé en
mars dans une maison de santé
je cherchais une installation en groupe
parce que j'avais travaillé souvent
rurales en médecins isolés
j'avais fait beaucoup de campagnes et au
bout d un moment ben voilà j'avais
voulu m'installer à plusieurs pour des
raisons de
proactivité on va dire du système de
santé d'être à plusieurs ça nous permet
de discuter sur des cas difficiles à
l'origine du projet ce jeune médecin
déjà praticiens sur la ville depuis 2014
il a choisi de s'installer durablement
un projet à plus d'un million d'euros
on a eu des réponses positives au niveau
de la région et au niveau de la rsr ps
qui nous ont permis en subventionnant
une partie de l'investissement du coup
d'agrandir notre surface de cabinet
médical est d'accueillir de nouveaux
professionnels de santé des appuis
techniques municipaux et des subventions
financières à hauteur notamment de
250000 euros
du côté de l' agence régionale de santé
et de l'union régionale des
professionnels de santé
d'abord faciliter l'immobilier puisque
l'immobilier est un coût important
en ile de france et donc dans le budget
économique d'un cabinet médical qui est
quand même une petite entreprise à magny
les hameaux c'est un pôle santé qui
s'est créée à l'été 2010 8 plus de
120000 euros de travaux dans l'ancien
pmi pour accueillir les patients dans le
quartier du buisson il n'y a plus de
généralistes depuis une quinzaine
d'années en centre ville il ya quatre
médecins ça ça doit faire cinq
équivalents temps pleins de médecins
mais dans un rayon de 200 mètres chacun
donc dans le quartier de l'hôtel de
ville
par contre ici où il y à la moitié de la
population environ 4500 habitants
il n'y a aucun généralistes en contact
avec la rs depuis deux ans la ville a
trouvé une solution
des consultations avancées d'un médecin
urgentiste de l'hôpital privé de trappes
il consulte chaque mercredi depuis le
mois d'octobre c'est pas la même façon
de travailler on les mêmes moyens
techniques mais c était un partenariat
et j'ai trouvé que c'était intéressant
de pouvoir faire un poste avancé de
l'hôpital et pouvoir dépanner les gens
et pouvoir les accueillir dans une
structure en avant de l'hôpital psy a
pas besoin du plateau technique une
relation ville-hôpital aussi envisagé à
plaisir la ville actuellement en
discussion avec la rs et le département
s'associe avec l' hôpital gérontologique
et médico social nous avons un terrain
qui est vraiment à l'entrée de cet
hôpital qui serait tout à fait le
terrain adéquat pour
voir faire cette maison médicale un
médecin pour déjà porté le projet et
ensuite je pense que avec toute
l'énergie que l'on met en place
actuellement on sent des frémissements
il y a des médecins il ya des gêné colog
par exemple qui se sont rapprochés de
nous on a des infirmières qui se
rapprochent de nous parce qu'il faut
aussi du paramédical
on a décliné certains généralistes
aujourd'hui la maison pourrait voir le
jour d'ici deux trois ans actuellement
la ville compte huit généralistes pour
près de trente deux mille habitants
[Musique]
à la verrière un cabinet médical vide
l'un des médecins étant obligé de partir
pour raisons de santé
l'autre ne pouvait plus assurer les
frais du cabinet seule la commune se
retrouve sans aucun médecin depuis huit
mois
j'ai encore un médecin mais qui à 67 ans
au mais nul quand il va partir je sais
pas ce que je ferais chier jurés à
l'hôpital qu'est ce que voulez qu'on
fasse donc on peut que ça peut pas durer
comme ça il faut construire une maison
de santé maisons de santé qui n'est
resté qu'au stade de projet suite à un
problème de santé suit aussi une
modification de la politique de la ville
qui ne souhaitait plus mettre un budget
dans la construction d'un cabinet et
qu'il voulait transférer le support
financier à la même semaine donc faire
venir des médecins au sein des mushers
donc lumière des accords avec les
médecins libéraux et depuis ce projet
est tombé à l'eau
on était sûr de 50 % des financements la
ville devant forcément de toute façon m
25 % et 25 % restants qui n'était pas
encore complètement acquis celle
organismes de mutuelle générale de
l'éducation nationale mgen qui a
finalement proposé d'ouvrir ses locaux
même jeu elle nous avait bien certifié
que grosso modo on pouvait occuper les
locaux comme un centre de santé que les
médecins étaient tout à fait libre
comme si c'était ailleurs une solution
intéressante financièrement pour les
collectivités locales mais qui inquiète
les médecins libéraux quant à leur
indépendance
le projet s'étend aujourd'hui acteurs de
la santé de la commune et municipalités
partagent la même inquiétude pour la
santé des 6000 habitants de la verrière
la mer a lancé des démarches auprès de
l' agence régionale de santé avec la
maire du mesnil saint denis une commune
voisine dont les médecins arrivent à un
âge avancé dernier recours en date de la
verrière une pétition adressée à la rs
qu'elle fait signer à ses habitants je
pense que la mairie de la verrière
avaient anticipé ce départ en retraite
voilà malheureusement pour l'instant ça
ne porte pas encore ses fruits mais je
pense que ça va se mettre en place de
manière progressive mais encore une fois
je vous rappelle le principe de libre
installation des médecins des médecins
qui peine à se laisser séduire par
l'offre actuelle malgré les aides
proposées la verrière est classé en zone
d'intervention prioritaire par la rs il
faut un projet il faut souvent que les
anciens amène ce projet et parce que ses
anciens auront créé un projet de
notamment de cabinets de groupe et c'est
qu'ils attireront les plus jeunes à
venir
une situation d'autant plus préoccupante
que la verrière portent des projets
d'aménagement et de développement de la
ville comme dans le quartier gare bécane
avec la construction de 1000 logements
[Musique]
ce dossier à revoir sur notre site
internet a commenté sur les réseaux
sociaux au rendez vous le mois prochain
sur tv 78
[Musique]